[Music]
hey you guys back once again for another
tomes of terror book review
and as i mentioned in my last review i'm
actually going to try and do some more
newer stuff you know stuff that came out
in the last few years that was available
to read on kindle unlimited because i've
sort of gone through
most of the print books that i had
wanted to cover and as i said you know
until i can afford to buy another pile
of print books because i do actually
prefer reading print books
i'm going to take advantage of my kindle
unlimited subscription and read some
stuff on there that was kind of highly
rated
again i know i said on my last one too
that i was gonna try and do um kind of
winter themed horror for the month of
december but then i realized when i
started reading this one that i was just
kind of like oh wait this isn't really a
winner themed
but i had been wanting to read this one
just because this one actually came out
in summer of 2019
but i just remember
a lot of hype about this one and a lot
of horror channels covering it from the
synopsis it sounded actually really good
so i was just kind of like well okay i
know it's not like winter related but it
is available to read for free if you
have kindle unlimited and so i decided i
was gonna dive right into it plus it was
very very highly rated on goodreads and
it was like four and a half four and
three-quarter stars or something i mean
there were a couple of one and two star
reviews but not really very many most
people really really seem to dig this
and honestly um i can see why now i will
say that this is not it's
not as much a horror it's scary but it's
more of like a thriller
than uh horror was kind of like a serial
killer type situation like child
abduction type thing
um and it's not real
gory or graphic
but it really is
good at it just has like a really
compelling story to it it has like a
really good
characterization um you know the the
characters you really feel for them and
you kind of like get in their heads so
even though it's not like over-the-top
horror in the sense that
you know it's not like monsters or
anything really it's more like a
thriller but
it's still like really creepy and it has
like some really creepy elements to it i
also like that it has sort of
i guess what you would call like a
paranormal element
but it's left ambiguous as to whether
it's actually a paranormal element or
not and i kind of liked that ambiguity
of it it's not real overwhelming
but
and some of this stuff later on could
have been
explained by rational means but maybe
not like maybe not necessarily so i like
that it kind of left the door open for
that
so this book is called the whisper man
and the author's name is alex north now
alex north is apparently a pseudonym
uh the author is he's from uh england
he's from leeds
and he's apparently written books under
another name but interestingly if you
look up alex norris like the alex north
author page on amazon it just says he's
published books under another name but
doesn't tell you what that name is so
it's like i guess this is a situation
because i know a lot of writers do this
where it's like if you're kind of known
for
writing something in one genre and then
you want to try out a different genre
then you just write under a pseudonym
and you don't really want the two things
to cross over so i get that so i don't
really know what alex north's real name
is or what
genre he normally writes in this is
actually his first crime thriller i
think he's written one more since then
and it's pretty [ __ ] great i gotta
say this was another one
that because i liked the last book that
i read so much autumn bleeds into winter
and even though i was like well i'm
getting so ahead on my book reviews just
because i've been wanting to read more
lately than watch movies i guess it just
kind of goes back and forth so i was
like well i need to do some more movie
reviews and watch those but it's like
man i really want to read another book i
was kind of all invigorated by like the
last one i read and i had already
checked this one out because i already
had all the december ones checked out in
my library and i was like what the hell
it's you know it's it's thanksgiving i'm
just kind of sitting around doing
nothing other than digesting food and i
just kind of felt like you know sitting
around and reading something
and uh honestly i finished a good this
isn't it's not a terribly short book i
think it's 350 pages something like that
um i finished 75 of this book in one
sitting like while i was just sitting
around on thanksgiving day
like
i'm doing this even though i was
actually reading it on my computer
because it's an e-book but you know
this is another book that just really
sucked me in from the first page and
just didn't let up and it was one of
those ones
that it just kept going and going and
just all these twists and turns and all
this stuff going on all this mystery and
all this creepy [ __ ] and it was just
kind of like it was just really really
good i enjoyed this one a lot uh so yeah
i did end up uh reading the last quarter
of it
you know the the day after thanksgiving
and you know then wanted to do a review
of it like as soon as possible
now apparently i heard
that
like either as soon as this book came
out or even a little bit before the book
came out uh the movie rights had been
purchased by the russo brothers like the
you know the guys that did the do all
the marvel movies i think they directed
avengers infinity war and a couple of
other ones
uh but i as of i think the last news i
heard of that was either late 2019 or
early 2020 so i don't know what's gonna
happen with that to me
this would probably make a good movie
but i kind of feel like it needs a
series because
there's a couple there's two or three
different like intertwining threads in
this and i sort of feel like
it maybe needs maybe like a mini series
you know i mean like maybe four episodes
or six episodes or something like that
so you can kind of like let the
characters breathe a little bit because
i do think that the characters
are the best part of this now the only
thing and this is not a criticism but
this is just something that that kind of
like threw me off at first
but then i got used to it the book
starts out in first person uh from the
point of view of tom kennedy
who's one of the main protagonists which
i'll get into in a bit
his part is in first person
all the other parts are in third person
so so it does kind of switch from first
person to third person depending on
whose perspective we're seeing it from
so
it's i don't know if that's going to
bother you or somebody it didn't bother
me it was just i was just kind of like
oh we're in first person oh we're in
third person now and now we're in first
person again so it was just that kind of
thing so you just kind of have to get
used to it switching back and forth
because it does follow a bunch of
different characters but the only
character that is told from the first
person is the character of tom kennedy
who starts uh the book like the kind of
pro-logging part
where he's ostensibly like writing to
his son you know and then we kind of
like unfold what happens so as i said
because this is a new book i don't
really want to well newish uh 2019. i
don't really want to spoil anything
about it especially because you know if
they do a series or a movie eventually
you know you kind of want it and this
one this one is one that actually does
have a lot of twists and turns and
revelations in it that are best left
unspoiled because sometimes like when
you read i was just kind of like whoa
holy [ __ ] you know what i mean it was
that kind of thing oh and i wanted to
say too that i love this there's even in
the e-book there's
they always do this kind of book club
thing if it's a book club pick they
always have like discussion questions in
the back and then they had an interview
with the author and he said that one of
the ideas like he was telling about
where he got the idea from this book
from
and there was a couple different stories
that he told all of which were pretty
cool but the one that was like really
creepy
was that he was he said i was watching
my son one day uh who i think was eight
at the time and he's like and i kind of
heard him talking to somebody like out
in the living room like he's out there
playing
and uh he's like and i knew nobody else
was there so i thought that was a little
weird so he goes out and he kind of
watches the kid and the kid's like
talking to nobody and he says you know
hey bud who are you talking to and the
kid says the boy in the floor
at which point i'd have been like ha ha
but you know what i mean it's that kind
of let's kids say the creepiest [ __ ]
kind of thing but that's one of the
things that um that he said like
inspired him to write this because that
actually does happen in this book
all right so what we have tom kennedy as
i said he's the one that's uh in first
person
now he uh has a son named jake who's
seven i think he's seven yeah and um
they have just lost he has just lost his
wife rebecca like in a very sudden way
like she wasn't you know she was just
like sick one day then she died and so
you know because they're fairly young
so they're kind of dealing with the
trauma of that it's been a while like
it's been a year and they decide
um they've been having some not so much
problems but
i think the reason that some of this
resonates so much is because uh you know
tom's character
is since it's from the first person
he's talking about his feelings about
how
you know how he's left to raise this
little boy alone
and the little boy jake is
one of those kids he's very very quiet
he's very precocious he's very creative
he's not real uh socially adept
and he mostly just likes to stay by
himself and draw
and
tom kind of implies that he was sort of
like that as a kid too although he
doesn't really remember it all that well
because he had kind of a shitty
childhood and so he's having a hard time
relating to the kid especially now that
uh his wife is gone because he felt like
his wife and his son had a much better
like a much easier more organic uh
relationship that he's having a really
difficult time replicating so he's
having a really hard time relating to
his son and he's really kind of
heartbroken about this like he feels
like he's sort of failing him
so he decides that the best thing for
them to do uh would be to move out of
the house where there were so many
memories because jake also found his
mother dead
and still has really like a lot of
trauma and nightmares about it because
it was such a horrible experience so he
thinks well maybe if we just get out of
this house
then you know everything we can kind of
like pick up and start over again
so they moved to this little town called
feather bank now interestingly the house
that they move into it's kind of old
and uh this is actually it's said in the
uk but it's not super like uk centric i
didn't even realize like other than a
couple turns of phrase uh i didn't even
realize that it was that it was the uk
so it's not real noticeable i guess i
don't know if that's a good or bad thing
but i'm just saying it's not super
noticeable this could kind of be
anywhere
like any kind of small town uh place
so uh so he moves to this place and the
house that they get it's like this kind
of weird looking
house that i guess back in the old days
all the kids thought was like the scary
house just because it was kind of funny
looking like nothing
nothing necessarily bad happen there
like no murders or anything but it just
it's just funny looking and it gave
people like a funny feeling however jake
saw it when they were looking through
houses online and he insisted that that
was the house that they had to have and
he just would not have it any other way
so you know he's so tom's trying to make
his son happy so he's like okay well
that's the house that we'll have so they
move in there
now it turns out that in this town of
featherbank 20 years ago
um five little boys were abducted and
murdered now four of the bodies were
found one of them was not
so the person that did this was a serial
killer who the media dubbed the whisper
man because one of the things that he
would do was he would kind of come up to
the kids
windows at night and like whisper to
them like to lure them out
now uh interestingly this serial killer
was caught his name was frank carter
and he was put in prison by a
detective inspector uh pete willis i
think his name is who is kind of like
he's still kind of on the force but he
seems like he's semi-retired
um but he still has an obsession about
the one little boy that wasn't found
like he knows that the little boy is
probably dead but the fact that he was
never able to completely close the case
even though he did catch the killer and
put him in prison where he still is to
this day um just that one kid still
being missing like not knowing where his
body is really haunts him so he kind of
goes and visits the serial killer every
now and then hoping like to get some
information out of him and it's kind of
like because i've seen this book sort of
compared to silence of the lambs it does
have a couple
minor similarities in the sense that yes
there is a detective character who
visits a serial killer to see if he can
find out where the last body is
and there is also like kind of a slight
thing to do with like kind of a
butterfly moth kind of thing but it's
very minor so
it is a little silence in the lambsy but
not really you know what i'm saying or
at least not any more than any other
crime thriller i guess you know what i
mean i don't know and honestly the the
aspect of the detectives still going
back and talking to this serial killer
it's not like a main part of the story
because this like i said this story has
a lot of like intertwining threads
a lot of them having to do with
the relationships between fathers and
sons you know traumatic childhoods and
if you're sort of if you can not
replicate them like when you get older
and have your own son you know
alcoholism abuse and stuff like that
when kids are younger and then you
trying to struggle to not be like that
anymore
so you have that detective character now
in the present day after tom and jake
have moved to this house and feather
bank
another little boy in the town goes
missing like it's right before they move
there
and the mo of it
seems
not exactly the same but very very
similar to the [ __ ] that happened with
the whisper man case 20 years ago
now obviously it's not the same guy
because that guy is in prison and they
got that guy like dead to rights like
the bodies were in his house and
everything and so they know that he did
it
but uh even 20 years ago there were some
kind of rumors swirling around that
maybe
he had an accomplice
and so maybe this accomplice is still
running around and after 20 years has
decided that they want to you know pick
up the mantle or whatever or perhaps
this is a copycat of some kind so
basically you're kind of going back and
forth between
the investigation
into uh this little boy neil spencer who
gets uh abducted and tried they're
trying to find him
and then um you know the detective going
back and like talking to
uh the the whisper man and trying to get
information out of him and then the the
[ __ ] that's going on with uh with tom
kennedy and jake his son now there does
seem to be
like i said there does seem to be some
kind of paranormal [ __ ] going on because
jake
um who like i said is a very kind of
sensitive child
it's
it's left ambiguous whether he actually
does have psychic powers or can see
ghosts or whatever but he's starting to
have like imaginary friends
in the sense that well he has this one
imaginary friend who's a little girl who
nobody else can see but him obviously so
so she comes to him and talks him about
things and you know seems to be sort of
a comforting presence but then when they
move to the new house um you know
there's kind of more a scary one like
you know the boy in the floor and that
kind of stuff and then there also seems
to be like weird human [ __ ] going on
where it's like one night jake
uh goes downstairs almost like he's
sleepwalking it's like he's gonna unlock
the door and it seems like there's a
dude like outside like trying to get in
the house like sticking his fingers
through the mail slot and whispering and
stuff like that and also there's this
dude who was like trying to get into
their garage which had a padlock on it
and acted kind of sketchy
so you so there's kind of all this weird
all these things like swirling around
this investigation and about this
missing boy so it's kind going back and
forth between
the relationship between tom and jake
jake acting kind of weird like acting
out and like saying all kind of weird
things that imply that he has that he
knows something about maybe what's going
on and also you're following the
investigation pete willis from the
original investigation he's like in his
50s now but there's also another
detective uh named amanda amanda beck
and um she's doing this current case but
she's kind of working in cahoots with
the older guy like because he works the
original case so they're trying to find
this one boy that got abducted before
you know he gets murdered and all this
other stuff and they're trying to link
it with the old case and that's pretty
much how it goes so as i said i liked
this book a great deal like i said it's
pretty much it just draws you right in
from the very beginning
and it just doesn't really let up it's
just there's always just kind of like
twists and turns and all kind of
different things going on and i really
liked after i got used to it switching
back and forth from first to third
person it didn't really like you know
like i said it was jarring at first you
know for the first chapter or two but
then i was like all right and then i
kind of got into the rhythm of it and it
jumps back and forth from you know the
first person which is tom kennedy uh
sometimes it's from jake's point of view
sometimes it's from amanda beck's point
of view sometimes it's from pete
willis's point of view so it jumps back
and forth uh between all these different
characters but it never gets muddled or
confusing um you always know kind of who
it is it's a
i don't want to say it's like it's not a
straightforward story necessarily
because it's kind of complex and there's
a lot of moving parts but he has a
really good uh sense of control over it
so it doesn't really go meandering off
or anything it stays very focused uh so
even though it's going back and forth
between different
povs
you still always have that thread
going on it doesn't really like jump
back and back and forth in time too much
or anything like that it always just
kind of like jumps around at different
characters and keeps moving forward and
so
in that sense once you start reading it
it's really really hard to put down
because you're just kind of like what
the [ __ ] is going on because there's
just like creepy [ __ ] creepy [ __ ] creep
[ __ ] and it's just all going all over
the place and there's always kind of
like a sense of danger too because you
know this kid got kidnapped or you know
is are the cops gonna find him before he
gets murdered and then like you know
other things happen later on and uh so
it's just it's a really great story i
mean like i said it's not if you read a
lot of thrillers um you know a lot of
people have said it was kind of similar
to silence at lambs and it's not exactly
it's not really
like that there's a couple of
very like minor similarities but other
than that i didn't find it all that much
like silence of the lambs but like i
said you know the thriller genre you're
going to get a lot of overlap in these
kind of like serial killer type of
stories so obviously you know there's
going to be similarities in that regard
but honestly this was just a really
enjoyable
uh read and it's it's actually pretty
creepy and it's like pretty scary and
you know so if that sounds like
something you would like like i said
there's it's kind of about child
abductions and child murders it's not
real graphic um it doesn't linger on you
know descriptions of
what happens to the kids it keeps that
pretty
subtle it's kind of more concerned with
the characters the relationships you
know the father-son dynamic
and sort of how the past impacts the
present so it's more focused on that
it's more focused on the atmosphere the
dread
things like that more than being like a
police procedural that's kind of
concerned about uh forensics but yeah if
that sounds like something you would
like this was actually a really really
good one if you have kindle unlimited
you can read it on there for free and i
would definitely recommend it it was you
know a great read a real page turner and
if you like creepy thrillers then this
should be right up your alley and as i
said um we'll see if they make it into a
movie or a series or something like that
if they do i'm totally gonna watch it
because it seems like it would be really
good but yeah that'll do it for this
tomes of terror and i will see you guys
on the next one bye